[Music]
we now enter
a new phase of the trump presidency
amidst the outrageous outlandish
left-wing chaotic
mob behavior of socialist democrats
american momentum is now around
winning the winning that outsider
candidate donald trump
promised us not the anarchy democrats
aka demon rats
want to impose on us the tactics of
these demon rats and trump-hating
leftists
are backfiring americans are now
buying into and choosing results
over politically correct losing behavior
of other presidents when the new york
times brett stephens and the wall street
journal's peggy noonan
both dug in trump haters say
senate democrats not only overplayed
their hand
but the democrats are blowing it
you know they sense what's coming
and it's not the blue wave that the
genius pundits predicted
they know they lost not just the
kavanaugh fight
but the american people along the way
americans don't like lies injustice and
they
certainly don't like vigilante or mob
justice the insanity that we witnessed
by those
suffering from trump derangement
syndrome
is both shocking and unprecedented
from being tossed out of restaurants to
being directed to harass
intimidate confront and make a crowd
around
anyone they don't agree with they
ramped it up even more during the
kavanaugh
hearings screaming interrupting
shouting down senators blocking them
from
voting and that are attempting to block
them from voting and then
in their feigned loser outrage
they claw on the doors of the united
states supreme court
as kavanaugh is being sworn in
americans are fair and they've had
enough
according to real clear politics
republican
senators in key states have dramatically
turned things around
cruz blackburn heller
mcsally and demon rat
corey booker who is now the
laughingstock of the senate
after likening himself to spartacus
fell flat off his chariot
and they justify their behavior
you cannot be civil with a political
party that wants to
destroy what you stand for what you care
about
hillary other than power cash and harvey
weinstein
and your own sexual predator husband
what the hell do you stand for and take
a listen to this one
michelle says that you know when they go
low
we go higher
when they go low we kick
[Applause]
that's what this new democratic party is
about
really eric you a former attorney
general of the united states
condone violence someone who thinks
beliefs and words justify physical
assault
did you even go to law school look
here's the bottom line we're not even
two years into trump's presidency
the economy record high unemployment
record low under president trump
americans saved two 3.2 trillion dollars
in taxes
3.3 million jobs
have been created the military is being
rebuilt
120 federal judges have been appointed
two united states supreme court justices
a much improved trade deal for the u.s
with canada and mexico
the stock market has hit historic highs
80 times 81 000
illegal aliens have been deported by ice
15 hostages have been brought home from
countries like north korea
iran venezuela and of course
just today pastor andrew brunson
from turkey so to all those
trump-hating demon rats and the
mainstream
media keep up the antics
you're all losers sore losers
stupid losers too dumb to even know that
you're losing
he said it himself just a few minutes
ago
in kentucky the only reason to vote
democrat
is if you're tired of winning
[Applause]
i don't know about you but i'm not tired
yet